The   moon   is   out,   everyone's   in   dreamland,
and   you've   tuned   into   the   Deb   of
Night.
Nobody   to   fall   asleep   next   to?
Go   ahead   and   pull   the   radio   into
bed.
That's   what   I'm   here   for.
And   hey,   why   don't   you   call   me
sometime?
Area   code   three   two   three,   KL5   KTRK.
Looks   like   somebody's   been   waiting   in   the
queue   quite   a   while   to   speak   to
yours   truly.
So   caller,   why   aren't   you   asleep?
Um,   uh,   insects.
Insects,   as   in   you   have   an   insect
problem,   or   chirping   crickets   are   keeping   you
up,   or   you   have   nightmares   about   them?
Help   me   out   here.
No,   no,   no.
Don't   you   know,   when   you   fall   asleep,
they   can   crawl   into   your   mouth,   or
your   ears,   or,   or   your   nose.
Y-   you   can't   prevent   it   if   you're
asleep.
I,   I   mean,   what   can   you   do?
Are   there   any   scientists   out   there   listening
to   this?
Um,   I,   I,   I   read   something,   I,
I   don't   know   where,   but   do   you
know   the   average   person   eats   several   pounds
of   insects   a   year?
The   majority   of   that   weight   is   composed
of   roaches,   ants,   and   spiders.
Just   knowing   that   as   soon   as   you
close   your   eyes,   a   big,   fat   centipede
is   gonna   drop   into   your   mouth   and
crawl   down   your   throat,   [panting]   I   can't
do   it.
I   never   sleep   at   night.
You   know,   they   voluntarily   eat   insects   in
some   countries.
Yeah,   well,   those   countries   probably   need   Jesus.
So   you   never   sleep   at   night.
I   assume   you   do   sleep,   right?
Uh,   I   sleep   at   work.
And   what   exactly   do   you   do?
I'm   a   middle   school   teacher.
That   would   explain   why   my   nephew   invested
that   20   I   sent   him   for   his
birthday   on   magic   beans.
It's   always   good   to   know   that   the
future   of   our   country   is   in   good
hands,   isn't   it?
Oh,   boy.
Let's   see   who   else   we   got.
Caller,   what   do   you   do   for   a
living?
I'm   Roger.
Okay,   and   what   do   you   do,   Roger?
Um,   I'm   a   writer,   Deb.
So   have   you   written   any,   uh,   movies
I   might   have   seen?
Well,   I   actually   haven't   finished   any   screenplays
yet.
I   see.
So   have   you   done   any   other   kinds
of   writing?
Well,   just   some   outlines   right   now,   but
I   got   some   really   good   ideas   for
some   stories   that   are   crawling   around   in
the   old   noggin.
[laughs]   So   if   you   haven't   really   written
anything,   how   can   you   call   yourself   a
writer?
Because   I   once   fixed   my   toilet   doesn't
make   me   a   plumber,   right?
Well,   you   see-   Is   there   anyone   in
this   city   that   doesn't   call   themselves   a
writer,   or   actor,   or   a   director?
Don't   you   think   you're   doing   a   disservice
to   those   who   actually   make   their   living
in   those   art   forms   by   deeming   yourself
something   you're   not   or   not   even   trained
to   do?
Um,   no,   I   think   I'm   pretty   good
at   knowing   what's   good   writing   from   bad
writing.
Well,   wouldn't   that   make   you   a   critic?
Let's   see   if   anyone   else   agrees.
Line   two,   are   you   ready   for   a
ménage   à   trois?
Sure   thing,   Deb.
And   would   you   please   state   what   you
do   for   a   living?
I'm   a   personal   assistant   for   a   producer
at   Parasite   Studios.
Perfect.
Do   you   read   a   lot   of   screenplays?
Don't   get   me   started.
Well,   for   our   writer   on   the   phone,
here's   your   big   chance   to   pitch   your
screenplay.
Is   that   okay,   line   two?
Sell   me,   dude.
Well,   um,   okay.
So,   uh,   my   story's   about   this   guy.
You   don't   say.
Okay,   o-   okay.
So   this   guy,   he's...
Well,   he's   like   a,   an   FBI   agent,
but,   you   know,   he   doesn't   really   work
for   the   main   FBI.
And,   uh,   he's   got   this   partner   who's
new   and   really   cute,   but   she's   also
a   really   good   agent,   and   they're   like
assigned   to   this   bizarre   case   where   people
are   being   killed   in   really   strange   ways.
Uh-huh.
And   then,   like,   something   happens,   and   the
girl   agent   gets   kidnapped   by   the   killer.
Something   happens.
Yeah,   well,   I   haven't   quite   figured   it
out   yet,   but,   like,   the   guy   agent
notices,   like,   how   the   killer   seems   to
know   everything   he's   doing,   like   one   step
ahead   of   him.
And   then   there's   this   kinda,   you   know,
weird   chase   scene,   and   then,   like,   we
find   out   that   the   guy's   got   two
personalities,   and,   like,   he   finds   out   in
the   end   that   he's   the   killer,   and
then   he's   kidnapped   his   own   partner.
Well,   line   two,   what   do   you   think?
You   gonna   option   it   or   not?
Uh,   writer   dude?
Roger.
Uh,   Roger,   would   you   like   my   professional
opinion?
Yeah.
Where   are   you   from?
Um,   Wisconsin.
Okay.
I   want   you   to   get   all   your
stuff   together,   and   then   I   want   you
to   move   back   to   Wisconsin.
That's   a   little   cold,   line   two.
That's   Hollywood,   baby.
Maybe   it's   just   too   good   for   you.
Uh,   no,   dude,   it's   not.
Break   it   up,   you   two.
Final   thoughts,   guys?
Wisconsin.
I   have   some   other   things   I'm   working
on,   too.
I   got   some   pretty   good   ideas   for
video   games,   I   think.
If   anyone's   interested   in   hiring   me,   my
number   is   two   one   three-   Sorry,   Roger,
the   only   one   that   gets   to   give
out   their   number   on   this   show   is
me.
And   if   anyone   was   thinking   of   asking
what   I'm   wearing,   that   number   again   is
three   two   three   KL5   KTRK.
We're   gonna   take   a   short   commercial   break,
but   that   doesn't   mean   you   can   stop
thinking   about   me.
Don't   go   anywhere,   boys.
Does   your   penis   always   seem   to   be
getting   in   the   way?
I   got   the   last   of   the   groceries,
honey.
I   just   need   to   close   the   trunk.
[trunk slams]   [screams]   One   more   nail   and   this
birdhouse   will   be   as   good   as   new.
[hammer hits finger]   [screams]   I'm   sorry,   sir,   this   dressing
room   is   for   women   only.
You   don't   have   to   let   this   happen
to   you.
Hi,   I'm   Dr.
Fred   Tuck.
Don't   let   your   penis   interfere   with   the
quality   of   your   life   anymore.
I   have   performed   over   300   sex   changes
in   my   career,   and   not   one   of
my   patients   has   ever   asked   for   their
tackle   box   back.
Come   to   Tuck's   Sex   Exchange   in   the
next   month,   and   I'll   give   you   a
free   estimate.
Don't   let   your   piece   interfere   with   your
peace   of   mind.
Tuck's   Sex   Exchange,   located   off   Beverly   Drive.
Look   for   the   sign   with   Toothy,   the
surgical   saw.
Tired   of   sluggish   internet   access?
Mom,   the   internet's   all   slow   again.
I'm   not   your   mom.
I'm   the   creature   that   evolved   out   of
your   mom.
Sick   of   unwanted   spam?
Oh,   oh,   another   email   message   from   my
old   college   roommate,   Rod   Eugies.
Oh,   oh   my.
Computer   problems   make   it   frustrating   to   log
on?
Error   432:   network   access   remote   server   memory
allocation   assessment   table   exceeded.
Hard   drive   reformatting   will   now   commence.
What?
Looking   for   something   that   requires   no   logons,
no   unwanted   email,   coherent   sentences,   and   no
technical   problems   whatsoever?
Read   a   book.
Books:   the   original   internet.
Terrorists   are   prepared   to   destroy   the   largest
dam   in   America   again.
Then   she-bomb   goes   off.
This   Hoover   will   be   caught   with   his
panties   down.
And   only   this   renegade   cop   and   his
ex-wife's   manicurist   stand   between   destruction   and   unexpected
love.
I'll   just   file   you   as   DOA.
[gunshot]   This   summer,   all   bets   are   off,
the   heat   is   on,   the   fix   is
in,   the   dogs   are   out,   the   game
is   up,   the   chips   are   down,   the
stakes   are   high,   the   odds   are   low,
the   danger   is   huge,   the   payoff   is
slim.
Friendships   will   be   made,   rules   will   be
broken,   wrongs   will   be   righted,   and   no
unturned   stone   will   be   left,   uh,   get
ready   to   be   turned   inside   out   and
upside   down.
[explosion]   Hoover   2:   Hydro   Electric   Boogaloo,   the
best   damn   movie   you'll   see   this   year.
When   I'm   grinding   the   reverse   Poindexter   540
to   ollie   northbound   to   contraband,   I   can't
think   about   being   bloated.
[fart]   That's   why   every   morning   I   down
a   Pound   Ground,   the   gentle   extreme   laxative
sports   drink.
Because   when   you're   pulling   a   wicked   skull
cross   720,   you   don't   want   anything   to
slow   you   down.